voy a multiplicar 16 por 27 y lo voy a
hacer usando una cosa que se llama
modelo de área y el objetivo del modelo
de área es que podamos entender qué es
lo que pasa en el proceso de la
multiplicación entonces 16 lo podemos
representar literalmente como 10 + 6 el
1 está en la posición de las escenas así
que representa 10 10
más
y voy a marcar estos 10 cuadros en azul
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 y para el 6 voy a
marcar 6 cuadros los voy a marcar en
verde 1 2 3 4 5 6 la parte azul es el 10
y la parte verde es el 6 el 10 es el 1
del 16 porque está en el lugar de las
decenas y el 6 son unidades ahora vamos
con el 27 lo podemos representar como 20
+ 7 el 2 está en la posición de las
decenas así que representa 20 y marcamos
20 cuadros 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 16 17 18 19 y 20 esta línea nos
indica el 20 y nos faltan 7 porque el
número 2 27 20 + 7 y el 7 lo ponemos por
acá
y marcamos 7 cuadros 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
si vemos bien los números 16 por 27 y
los multiplicamos el producto de ellos
nos da el área que tenemos aquí 16
cuadros por 27 cuadros y déjenme marcar
el área que representa el producto de 16
por 27 aquí tengo la altura de mi
rectángulo que es 27
y el ancho bueno 27 de alto y el ancho
es de 16 el área de este rectángulo es
16 x 27 es el área total del rectángulo
y lo que podemos hacer ahora es dividir
este rectángulo para poder calcular el
área de una manera más fácil y podremos
ver las diferentes áreas que representan
los productos de estos números que
tenemos aquí por ejemplo aquí tenemos 10
pies de ancho y voy a dibujar una línea
para separar las secciones este es el 10
de ancho y aquí también voy a dibujar
una sección de 20 de alto
bueno ahora podemos calcular el área de
cada una de las secciones para obtener
el área del rectángulo completo que es
igual al producto de estos números y es
la suma de estas áreas que tenemos aquí
entonces lo primero que podemos hacer es
pensar cuánto es 20 por 10 y es una
multiplicación muy directa es igual a
200 si pensamos en 2 por 1 es igual a 2
y tenemos dos ceros aquí o tal vez no
tienen la mente 20 por 10 es igual a 200
así que lo voy a escribir aquí 20 por 10
es igual a 200 y déjenme poner un poco
de color a esta sección le voy a poner
azul unas líneas azules que corresponden
al 10 estas líneas azules corresponden
al número 10 y también le voy a poner
unas líneas naranjas y estas líneas
naranjas corresponden al 20 y así
podemos reconocer que esta área es el
producto de 20 por 10 ahora cuánto es 20
por 62 por 6 6 12 y tenemos un 0 aquí
así que 20 por 6 es igual a 120
y lo escribo aquí y también voy a poner
unas líneas naranjas aquí porque estamos
multiplicando 20 por 6 estas líneas
corresponden al 20 y voy a poner líneas
verdes también que corresponden al 6 y
vemos que esta área representa el
producto de 20 por 6 y qué pasa con esta
área que tenemos aquí abajo 7 de alto
por 10 de ancho 7 por 10 es igual a 77
decenas es igual a 70 representa 70
cuadros y pongo aquí unas líneas rosas
que corresponden al 7 y unas líneas
azules que corresponden al 10 y por
último esta área que tenemos aquí tiene
7 de alto por 6 de ancho así que 7 por 6
es igual a 42 tiene un área de 42
cuadros y voy a colorear con rosa por el
7 este rosa corresponde al 7
y con verde por el 6
ahora si podemos calcular el área
completa de este rectángulo que es igual
a 200 más 120
70 + 42
y el resultado es 2 en las unidades y
aquí tenemos dos decenas más siete
decenas más cuatro decenas es igual a 13
decenas que es lo mismo que tres decenas
y una centena y por acá tenemos cien más
doscientos más 100 es igual a 400 y el
resultado es 432 esta multiplicación es
igual a 432 el producto de estos números
es 432 y probablemente se pregunten para
que hicimos todo esto si pudimos haber
resuelto esta multiplicación escribiendo
16 16 x
27 x 27 y resolverla con el método que
probablemente hayan aprendido y aquí
empezamos con el 7 en la posición de las
unidades y hacemos 7 por 6 42 y
escribimos aquí el 2 y llevamos 4 y este
4 lo escribimos en el lugar de las
decenas porque representa 40 y es aquí
cuando hacemos 7 por 6 que estamos
calculando esta área y luego hacemos 7
por 1 en realidad estamos calculando 7
por 10 porque este uno está en el lugar
de las decenas y cuando hacemos 7 por 10
realmente estamos calculando esta área y
luego llevamos 4 y sumamos y vemos aquí
que en realidad estamos calculando toda
el área de abajo que corresponde a 7 por
16 es la suma de estas dos áreas 7 por
10 más 6 y 7 por 1 es 74 es igual a 11
el resultado es 112 y cuando obtenemos
este 112 vemos que es esta área de abajo
es la suma de 70 más 42 y ahora vamos al
lugar de las decenas
y probablemente digan bueno aquí tengo
que escribir un cero pero cuál es la
razón por la que escribimos un cero aquí
abajo bueno porque este 2 representa
decenas si multiplicamos 2 por 6 y
ponemos el 2 del 12 aquí sería
incorrecto porque este 2 representa 20
por eso es que escribimos este 0 voy a
quitar este número de aquí para que no
se confundan y hacemos 2 por 6 es 12 y
escribimos el 2 aquí y llevamos 1 y
fíjense bien en realidad estamos
haciendo 20 por 6 que es 120 y es igual
al área que tenemos de este lado estamos
calculando esta área y luego hacemos 20
por 10 es igual a 200 pero llevamos uno
de 120 y esto es igual a 300 300 y lo
que hicimos al multiplicar este 2 por 16
fue calcular esta área 20 por 6 es igual
a 120 y 20 por 10 es igual a 200 cuando
hicimos 20 por 6 obtenemos 120 llevamos
a este 1
de las centenas y cuando sumamos
obtenemos 320 y luego en este paso
tenemos el área combinada tenemos que
sumar el área de aquí abajo más el área
de arriba
qué es 200 más 120 320 20 es 212 es 31
34 432